this
i've been outside
i don't know what's going on what's the
means what's the latest memes i gotta
know
i'm probably a couple months late on
this one couple years
but i just saw morbius at the cinema and
it was the greatest experience of my
life it made moving to japan worth it
209 audience score 212
000 to me
i have seen this movie
two
thousand times
you can say it's all lives that this
movie is actually not good but the
numbers don't lie okay this movie
grossed 352
trillion
worldwide if you think that's a lie get
more done you don't understand math and
how it works so yeah uh this movie came
out it was amazing some people like to
clown in this movie saying that no one
actually watched things slanderous
lights
how could they let's fight somewhere
empty more beats yeah that's really
funny
just because there's been 900 other
marvel movies people getting tired of
them i don't think so it features
everyone's favorite actor jared legendo
obviously it's gonna be a smash hit
success
who doesn't love that guy hey buddy
hey yo you with your fingers and your
chin beard what are you sitting on your
[ __ ] ass for
uh
this is the 30 seconds tomorrow show
okay
[Applause]
if you can't stand up you better be up
off your [ __ ] ass right now you hear
oh my god amanda's trying to bully your
audience to watch you well it worked
because morbid's greatest build i love
it you kids have your fun with batman
let the real men take it from here
mobius
i'm about to go more big morbius is so
big that it actually won the general
election which i think is pretty awesome
people were praising batman its
competitor saying that it hit 700
million in the box office morbius did
that while sleeping
who cares variety posted morbius drew 10
million at the box office this weekend a
catastrophic
74 drop from its opening i don't know
you could drop it lower than
considering dismal review
season that some fans have deemed the
summer of morbius may no longer be
within reach
no
this was supposed to be the summer of
morbius
slanderous media slanderous leftist
media you can come for me but you come
from my man morby it's a problem
okay so i'll show some proof that this
is doing really well here's a live
audience reaction from kohima kojima
kojima-san please collaborate with me i
am in japan now you're going
here's another
live audience reaction
you had to be there dr strange
the illuminati will see you now meet the
doctor michael
i shot this on my phone
so you know it's real
just watch more bs with all my morbius
head i am part of the morbius army
nation how about you guys leave a
comment about your favorite more moment
i have a theory actually because
everyone says citizen kane best movie of
all time has anyone actually seen
citizen kane actually works both ways no
one has seen morbius either it could be
the greatest film of all time no one
knows because no one's seen it so people
are taking this the fact that no one
actually went to see this movie and
making stuff about it but i have seen it
six times he does in fact say it's
morbid time it's at the one hour 12
minute mark he says
it was it was my favorite i got chills
when i saw it
i'm more of my pain tom movies is no
longer screening in this theater you
need to leave but we're going to call
the proper authority
you ain't lived unless you'd have the
morbius popcorn cup with the soda drink
that's probably quite rare if you think
about it
what if peter took the garlic snapped
and said to tony i just wanted to be
like you i just wanted to be like yo as
his drawing words what if morbius took
the gauntlet snapped and said it's
morbid time
so yeah
passing on the question to you guys have
you morphed yet
what was it like
what did it taste like have you
discussed it with the your parent or
parental guardian of the night next may
all right more morbius means i like them
i know they're a little den i know
i'm way behind on these but they're
still funny give it a good
seven quick word from sponsor i may be
in japan but there's one thing i don't
have gpu
lucky for me there's memorial dale pogo
sale
booger sale
buy one get one a great chance for you
to save a ton of money by stocking up
buy one get one g fuel support your
favorite creators by using their code
in a world that has
thousands of energy drinks g-fuel is the
greatest one no bias okay
if you drank it as well you would know
you already know pewdiepie lingonberry
is the greatest flavor of all time
there's also yusu slash which is
incredible flavor to contrast with but
the great part about g field is to have
they have a ton of different flavors
where you can pick and choose and find
your favorite one there that'll
definitely be a flavor that you will
enjoy in there they have the ellen green
crimson tears which i have not had the
chance to try that seems so cool naruto
sage mode i have tried that delicious
they also have flavor fusion which is a
combination of one of my favorite
flavors which is sour cherry combined
with blue eyes sounds good there's 50
different to pick from so yeah what are
you waiting for stock up on some g fuel
it's the greatest drink of all time i
absolutely love it i can't wait to get
mine
link is in the description use the bogus
sale guys this happens only a couple
times a year like if you're thinking
about sucking up on g fuel now's the
time and now it's the time only
okay
all right
patrick bateman back at it again
the movie then never stops delivering
the memes
historically i mean i remember no i
don't remember because i had no idea the
the doubles post the sex scene memes
we've all done that the patrick bateman
walking memes
of course everyone's seen the card memes
new card
what do you think
very nice
look at that picked them up from the
printers yesterday
good coloring that's bone
bone cubone get it i got it there's just
so many patrick bateman memes and they
just
keep
coming i love all the people online that
are like well people that idolize
characters like patrick bateman from
american psycho clearly shows that you
didn't get it you didn't get the film
it's like what
oh so you're saying when he steps on a
dog i'm supposed to not like that
he's a bad guy
i missed that point completely i was
just going oh that's awesome you didn't
get it he's supposed to be a bad okay
cool
i guess there's something to say about
it being um criticism on materialism and
people are still i i guess through memes
subconsciously playing it up as his
ideal figure who [ __ ] cares the memes
are funny now he's back at it again with
that why is it possible means i love
these they're so impossible it's just
not why not you stupid bastard it's got
4 million views holy sh that popped off
god damn
that's great why isn't it possible watch
everyone in the comment explaining it
there's a real reason why oh really you
can't do that what so you're saying that
if i
sit on this chair and i lift myself up i
won't just start flying
what
thank you reddit for explaining that wow
i'm glad there's all these smart people
in the comments
it's actually quite easy to explain well
you see the forces are cancelling each
other out but for real why is it not
possible explain why i don't get it if
everyone is so goddamn smart explain
this 77 plus 33 equals 100 isn't it
possible it's just not why not you
stupid bastard it's a hundred it's
clearly a hundred seven plus three is
ten
seven plus three is a hundred it's
hundred and ten oh
why isn't it possible it's just not why
dig to china
why not
[Music]
i have some good news
it is possible
you can make a portal
[Music]
thank you minecraft finally something
good in 2022 at last
i rate
an eight
next meme involves
private information
trauma
physical and emotional abuse
but i just hate this bit so much that
it's worth meaning amber heard also
known as amber turd i mean everyone's
already followed this i assume at least
i actually remember you guys telling me
about this on the subreddit i don't know
how i responded but uh justice for
johnny has been going on for a long time
i remember i'm really glad everyone is
showing him support it's so obvious just
basing on his character that he's a good
guy and watching all the everything
that's come out of this trial so far has
only been in his favor i feel like
there's just so much to break down and
there's so many things about this thing
but i just love this clip so much
so i just smiled made a joke about how
trashed the trailer got and
we had to get the
manager uh who started off furious
that johnny had wrecked the thing
and then
he had this like black mesh tank top and
not tanked out that was like a meshy
kind of shirt what the [ __ ] is she
talking about what are you talking about
this is not relevant she speaks exactly
how people do when you reverse something
like
too many times and you start going like
so like i think what the thing is about
the thing is like i just am speaking
like i haven't thought about this at all
anyway guys
she's also saying nothing and then she
just just dropped this line out of
nowhere we walked out of the trailer at
some point
my dog stepped on a bee we went to the
bed what
i think i see i think i'm actually on to
something there with the whole rehearse
thing i mean obviously i'm not like you
should probably think about we should
you're gonna say in a trial but it's so
bizarre like what the [ __ ] is she doing
with her face
my dog this is an actress
we went to the bet
and went on she just showed she's like
the worst actors of all time my dog
stepped on a bee oh yeah
my dog stepped on a bee
amber's telling lies about me
so how do you know amber we work
together on aquaman so
you work together as actors right no
well amber and i were in the pool
recording the scene it was just the two
of us and she pointed at the water said
look at that beautiful
brown fish
i don't understand
what was it
well it was uh shall i say amber's turn
the fact that i generally thought this
was real because this trial has been
crazy as hell yeah i feel like you could
easily get swept up with people being
charming but still being bad people i
feel like that's a common thing where
people can hide
bad personalities through yeah just
charm but it's also very clear with the
how to differentiate those kind of
people and i feel like johnny has none
of those traits that's just from what i
can tell and also nothing from this
trial has made me think oh wow i can't
believe johnny depp had did something
horrendous like he's being accused of so
you know this isn't much of a meme this
is me saying justice for johnny so i'm
not gonna rate it
but that's all the memes i had for today
remember to check out morbius it's out
on cinema right now you don't want to be
a non-morbid person listen i know it's
old memes but at least i'm not coming
out of the woodwork and explaining them
a day after they come out guys anyway
this is the joke if you're a morbid head
smash like on this video right now and i
see you more obvious in the morbid
leagues
more pissed